folks let me make a case for the best
snow removal attachment for your tractor
the kiss principle at its finest no
moving Parts no extra connections no
shoots the clog no Shear bolts to break
and no hoses to leak it's good for dry
fluffy snow wet heavy snow two inches of
cleanup two feet of deep stuff great for
gravel asphalt concrete or pavers what
makes this HLA Pusher better than the
rest there's no cross braces on the
inside to trap snow a rolled back to
propel snow forward making it easier on
your tractor the huge fully enclosed
Back Drag I haven't seen another one
like this great to roll your pusher
forward and pull snow away from a
retaining wall a garage door or a parked
car all the wear points are replaceable
and the bolts we got to design allows
for flexibility as your needs change and
maybe best of all it's cheaper than a
plow or a snow blower so for all these
reasons it's no wonder this is our
number one snow removal attachment we
sell every year so get yours at
goodworkstrractors.com we ship all over
the country every day of the week
[Music]